you an art and been keeping in touch uh  yeah we talked yeah well Mischa Barton  and her Dancing with the Stars partner  Artem might be doing more than just  talking because the pair stepped out for  a date night Wednesday just trying to  get to know each other it's very  promising so I'm gonna say very  promising a source tells ET the pair has  indeed started dating enjoying dinner  Wednesday at romantic French eatery the  little door in La our source says Artem  is the reason Misha has been looking  happier and healthier recently quote she  has become a giddy when talking about  him and quite smitten with him after  dinner the new couple moved over to the  Chateau Marmont where Misha introduced  Artem to some of her friends I feel like  there's so much more potential in here